carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
les doy la bienvenida a este nuevo
número de carrusel de las artes desde
una institución cultural de primera
categoría en la capital francesa el
centro pompidou de parís desde aquí
tengo el agrado de presentarles este
programa especial dedicado a la
historieta y el cómic a acompáñenme
[Música]
iremos a la exposición dedicada al
estadounidense chris ware uno de los
dibujantes de historietas más
revolucionarios del mundo autor de obras
como fabricar historias o jimmy corrigan
el chico más listo del mundo
conversaremos con una dibujante que ha
roto todos los moldes la francesa
penelope bayo autora de una obra
feminista en un mundo que durante mucho
tiempo fue dominado por los hombres y
conoceremos a un dúo español que ha
puesto de moda el cómic detectivesco
animal juanjo guarnido y juan díaz
canales son los autores del exitoso
blacksad un cómic protagonizado por un
gato negro que se ha convertido en una
verdadera superestrella
no
estamos en la biblioteca pública de
información que funciona en el centro
pompidou para el arte moderno y
contemporáneo de parís y hemos venido
hasta acá para descubrir la exposición
sobre chris ware uno de los autores de
historietas más importantes del mundo y
aquí nos espera la responsable de la
muestra
[Música]
emanuel pajón muchísimas gracias por
recibirnos aquí en la biblioteca pública
de información en el seno de esta
exposición dedicada a cage web un autor
que para los que ama la historieta es
casi un dios viviente pero si yo le
preguntara si yo le pidiera que nos
dijera por qué es tan aclamado que nos
diría a los comerciantes antes que nada
estamos muy contentos de recibir al
carrusel de las artes en esta exposición
le diría que chris ware es un artista
que con un lenguaje único ha logrado un
vínculo muy estrecho entre la imagen y
el texto pero además es alguien que
restituye en la historieta lo que
algunos llaman las paletas de la memoria
que son esas capas que se crean a medida
que vivimos y que constituyen la
complejidad de nuestra existencia como
nos encontramos en la intersección entre
nuestro pasado y nuestro presente y como
vivimos esa realidad y sueños aquí
presentamos muchas planchas originales
en las que se puede apreciar cada
detalle
íntima de sus relatos tomos un chaval
[Música]
para cuando se habla de chris ware hay
que hablar de un autor que tiene más de
25 años trabajando una obra inmensa
perdido quisiera destacar un álbum que
fue publicado en el 2000 jimmy corrigan
el chico más listo del mundo porque fue
un álbum muy aclamado por la crítica y
por los lectores su traje de un símil
kubica efectivamente jimmy corrigan fue
el álbum con el que chris ware saltó a
la fama es una obra de casi 400 páginas
sobre un hombre normal con un trabajo
ordinario casi un antihéroe un día me
recibe una carta de su padre al que no
conoce porque abandonó a la familia
cuando era muy pequeño es un relato que
habla de la afiliación de la familia de
quienes somos parece sencillo pero en
realidad son cuestiones complejas y en
la obra de chris ware nada es sencillo
todo es materia para una reflexión
profunda sobre la existencia y emociones
de ponce demostró que su minuto se decía
que chris webber no es un autor fácil no
es nada sencillo y justamente algunos
lectores de streetwear destacan esa
dificultad de leerle esa poca
accesibilidad la lectura de software la
lectura de las obras de chris ware
necesitan es verdad una gran
concentración
hablamos de jimmy corrigan pero hay
otras obras que son mucho más accesibles
menos melancólicas e incluso lúdicas por
ejemplo building stories que es una obra
en forma de caja con 14 fascículos de
formatos distintos sobre la vida de los
habitantes de un edificio cada lector
puede leer esas historias en el orden
que quiera y componer como lo desee la
historia de esos personajes del sector
de usted mismo y dulces débito
[Música]
r
gracias de manuel bien por recibirnos en
esta biblioteca pública de información
en el seno de la exposición crisisss web
exposición gratuita para el público y
nosotros vamos a seguir nuestra
exploración del mundo de la historieta
esta vez de la mano de una dibujante
francesa que ha roto todos los moldes y
que es considerada como lager power del
mundo del cómic se llama penélope bello
y sus historias y ficciones están
basadas en las historias de mujeres
fuertes atípicas pero a veces
desconocidas ellas e impuestos en un
mundo que a veces ha sido dominado por
los hombres no las presenta melissa
barra
[Música]
y
la francesa peugeot ha pasado los
últimos años sacando de los vídeos
historias femeninas como la de clint
índole jardinera barbuda voluntaria en
la primera guerra mundial
crema de montaña
siendo magnética o como las hermanas
mirabal en república dominicana
activistas y mártires de la dictadura de
trujillo cuyos asesinatos inspiraron la
instauración del día internacional de la
eliminación de la violencia contra la
mujer
relatos que plasmó en 2017 en la serie
de valerosas
quería hablar de todas esas mujeres
interesantes que ocupaban muy poco
espacio en los libros quise hablar de
ellas y me puse a leer un montón de
biografías fue así como dibuje dos
álbumes de historieta sea para dar a
conocer la vida de 30 mujeres
especialmente interesantes de las que
casi no se hablan
y
el 2022 versión fue nominada al gran
premio de angulema la máxima distinción
en el sector de la historieta
históricamente muy masculina
[Música]
situada candás con sus restos la
dificultad de ser autora de historietas
es tener que afrontar más obstáculos me
hubiera gustado tener modelos de autoras
a cuando era pequeña porque no las había
este año fuimos tres finalistas mujeres
algo impensable hace cinco años ha
emergido una nueva generación de
lectoras las chicas ya no aceptan que
las historias no sean escritas para
ellas en los últimos diez años de cada
vez son más autoras hacia atreven a
contar sus historias siempre ocuparse de
quiénes serán los lectores que son para
contados
en el ovario empezó en los años 2000
como un fenómeno en línea con su blog
titulado irónicamente mi vida es
absolutamente fascinante después de
ellos de fin y la adaptación de la
novela las brujas de roldán publicó el
estat un álbum sobre su juventud
esta es una historieta autobiográfica no
sabía si iba a interesar a la gente y si
era buena idea exponer mi vida de esa
forma pero para ser realmente sincera
con los lectores no podía ocultar a los
episodios duros de que cuento en el
libro en el hablo de duelos y de
agresiones sexuales por ejemplo este
tipo de experiencias se me convirtieron
en lo que soy hoy como para muchas
mujeres hacen parte de mí y hay que
contar las campos se aproximan don julio
de rossi
con nueve álbumes publicados en el
ovario y se ha convertido en todo un
fenómeno editorial que ha sido traducido
en 20 idiomas y adaptado en una serie de
televisión con más de 12 millones de
visitas
gracias mi lista barra y si en esta
ocasión hemos dedicado nuestro programa
a la historieta es porque es uno de los
sectores editoriales más dinámicos en
francia- en 2021 se vendieron 85
millones de álbumes de historietas
novelas gráficas y mangas que generaron
unos 900 millones de euros
[Música]
y hoy vamos a descubrir una de las sagas
más exitosas publicadas en francia pero
que es en realidad el fruto de la
colaboración de dos artistas españoles
ellos crearon hace 20 años blacksad las
aventuras de un gato detective que ya va
por su álbum número 6
[Música]
hacía ocho años que john black sad se
hacía esperar por sus lectores el
elegante gato detective está de regreso
a nueva york en la ciudad que lo vio
nacer toca en primera parte es el título
de este sexto tomo que vibra al ritmo de
la vida cultural neoyorquina su pirámide
social y sus mafias
[Música]
teníamos ganar de alguna manera de tener
una historia que tuviera resonancias que
nos recordara un poco al principio de la
serie es decir un black sad en su ciudad
en su oficina y trabajando en una
investigación pura y dura del detective
privado claro la ciudad de nueva york
nos ofrece un montón de temas y entre
ellos el tema un poco social los
grandísimos contrastes que hay en la
ciudad de nueva york las diferentes
capas de la sociedad y sobre todo el
gran contraste entre los que están
arriba los que están abajo
como en los álbumes anteriores los
protagonistas de este tomo son animales
con morfología humana pero con conductas
asociadas a cada animal
un personaje de solomon es muy típico
muy representativo de la manera en que
nos gusta a nosotros jugar con el tema
animal si sólo hemos pasado en un arcón
siempre está en su atalaya siempre está
en lo alto de todo el acápite y además
en lo alto de una viga sobre el vacío se
comporta como como si estuviera volando
como si realmente estuviera por encima
de todo y es realmente su actitud ante
ante la vida en el poder que él se
arroga y con cada animal intentamos
hacer uso de las posibilidades que la
cultura general atribuye a esos animales
entonces son mensajes que regularmente
son un poquito sutiles incluso
subliminales pero funcionan porque todo
el mundo los puede comprender
[Música]
en el caso de los trabajadores del metro
que al contrario que el ave rapaz que
vive en las alturas en su atalaya como
dice juanjo son todos animales de
madriguera prácticamente son animales
que viven en el subsuelo y representan
esa cara oculta digamos de la ciudad
donde pasan muchísimas cosas pero pasan
a
cubierto y una vez más nos sirve de
reflejo al metro de cualquier ciudad
[Música]
en 20 años black sad se ha convertido en
una saga de culto en francia con más de
2 millones de ejemplares vendidos y los
autores prometen una segunda parte de
todo cae en un futuro no muy lejano
[Música]
hemos visto que la gente ha acogido muy
bien sobre todo la parte del continuará
no que a nosotros particularmente por
nos gusta más que una frustración es una
promesa de algo que está por venir
totalmente el continuará es algo que no
ha hecho soñar tantísimo en todos los
que vemos los jóvenes que elegimos de
pequeños es para el público la promesa
de que viene un black hat muy rápido
[Música]
ya nos toca cerrar este programa
especial dedicado a la historieta y el
cómic que les presentamos desde la
biblioteca pública de información del
centro pompidou de parís muchísimas
gracias por su amable sintonía y hasta
la próxima en carrusel de las artes por
efe y france 24
[Música]
e